Amanda boulion est la plus jeune de la
famille du cirque Joseph boulion si la
benjamine fait ses premiers pas sur la
piste du chapitau son grand frère André
lui maîtrise déjà le
diabolo je suis né dans le cirque donc
depuis tout petit j'y suis mais j'ai
vraiment commencé à faire du CIRC quand
j'avais dizaine d'années 10 12 ans
environ moi je préféris jeage c'est plus
amusant c'est fait d'envoyer des choses
en l'air attraper qu'est-ce que tu
envoies justement comme j'envoie des
massus des bagues des cerceau des
diabolos je suis un jour un peu povalent
je fais un peu de tout au mois de
septembre André boulion part avec un
autre artiste James Micheletti au
Festival de cirque d'almati au
Kazakhstan pour ma part j'ai jamais
vraiment fait de festival c'était une
première plus ou moins et bah il y a des
facteurs qui rent en compte qu'il y en a
pas dans les spectacles habituels dont
le stress alors forcément après le
premier spectacle là-bas une certaine
déception normal et après bon ça s'est
pas trop mal passé en effet James
Micheletti et André boulian ont remporté
chacun une médaille de bronze une belle
surprise pour ces jeunes artistes qui
d'ordinaire partagent la vedette avec un
clown des chevaux des dromadaires et des
tigres au total près de 80 animaux on
est très généraliste dans la famille je
vais du dressage des chevaux tigres et
tous les animaux à l'organisation
la création des spectacles c'est vrai
que les fauves il a y a il y a un petit
piment en plus quand on est avec eux en
cage qui est donné par le danger la
possibilité du danger c'est une
rencontre avec donc ma future épouse à
l'époque Sandrine qui qui est ma femme
maintenant qui a comme elle est arrivé
chez nous avec des tigres et on est
tombé amoureux puis forcément sa passion
m'a intéressé de plus en plus le cirque
itinérant boulion son chapit sur le parc
du château de plaisir il présente son
spectacle rock and roll Circus jusqu'au
21 octobre deux autres dates à retenir
samedi 6 octobre pour un concert de jazz
manouche avec chavolo Schmid puis
mercredi 10 octobre pour une conférence
de dressage avec André
boulion